[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon everybody
it is my great pleasure to welcome you
to our session here with eth meets
berlin
rethinking materiality
my name is chris lupkoman i am the head
of foresight at the eth in zurich and
i'll be your host today
for our session and we'll be spending
about an hour together plus or minus
it is really it's my first time here in
the museum it's an incredible location
the museum from turkunda here in berlin
and we're surrounded by and this room
right now where we're in with incredibly
beautiful stuffed birds of all different
colors
and shapes and sizes from around the
world and we're walking around a little
bit before
i think anything and everything has been
jarred or stuffed to be displayed here
it's been quite incredible this event is
part of the berlin science week
this is a time
when berlin's science community
brings international scientists and the
science-driven organizations together
to have a stage to share insights into
some current topics
discuss grand challenges
and quite frankly to envision
our future together and this is really
what our session today is going to be
about when we're thinking about where
materials are heading
we're combining
for this living materials
so
the topic
all of us feel and know that we're at
the cusp of many many many great changes
around the world economically
politically from a climate standpoint
but we're also at a cusp in the change
in the way we fundamentally understand
the opportunities which science is
presenting to us and especially in
materials
we're able to now do things which
frankly
the the say the the grandfathers and
grandmothers in material science just
even dreamt about
and now we're at the cusp of being able
to do that to integrate smart materials
in our built environment
to mix sort of
living and non-living
items together
and to actually
look at 3d printed structures the end
it's almost impossible to imagine an end
to what we can do
and this session today this meeting
today is really about a conversation
so i'm happy to be here and we have
three guests you don't really want to
hear me talk much longer
i'm going to be hosting we're going to
make sure we close at an hour we're
going to three short presentations sort
of brain food and then we're going to
have a chance for you to ask questions
and you online as well you're gonna be
able to ask questions through slido i
encourage you to
pop your questions in i'll do my very
best to integrate them into our
conversation and we'll have microphones
here further in the room
so our first our three guests first we
have christiana sauer
she is an architect and a professor for
material design at the weisen say school
this is hard to see here i'm going to
come into the weisenstein school of art
and design here in berlin sort of a
homie as we would say
in her work she bridges material
experimentation and design
implementation focusing on textile
structures and active materials so
christianity welcome come on up
just give her a hand say well come on
that's okay come on here we go
and then thank you very happy to be here
today
good now we're gonna go i'm gonna bring
all three on stage
right yep okay then second we have mark
tibbett
mark tibbett is an assistant professor
of macro molecular engineering at the
eth in zurich his research focuses on
the interface between living and
non-living materials
and very specifically he engineers soft
materials to guide and control living
systems for engineering design let's
welcome mark mark welcome come on up
fantastic and last and not least i've
got to find my note on my friend massimo
massimo
portin caso he was the co-founder and
executive chairman of the ofici
officine
did i get it right officine
bio
the first his first distributed bio farm
i say his first because i'm sure he'll
do a lot more he's also the chairman of
hello tomorrow an investor and advisor
to startups and deep tech funds
we got to know each other when he was
the former managing director and partner
at boston consulting
and is a renowned author and speaker on
deep tech his work has been featured in
many many many magazines and places on
stages fast company bloomberg harvard
business review et cetera et cetera so
let's welcome massimo
okay
so as i said our time together is not
about 55 minutes and christian is going
to give a first impulse and then mark
and then massimo and then we're going to
talk for a little bit
and then you're going to get to ask
all the questions you would like to ask
so that's a perfect tool thank you
yeah very happy to present to you today
my perspective on new materials or
designing materials so as an architect
as a designer
of course materiality plays a central
role
i want to talk to you today about the
idea of fiber in material design so
fibers we can also find of course in
nature everywhere and it's super
interesting because fiber exists
throughout the scales
so from fibers being produced by
bacteria as we see here in this
bacterial cellulose biofilm
to fibers that are produced of course in
wood as we know
up to biological fibers like muscle
fibers fibrils and tendons for example
all these fibers throughout the scales
it's super interesting because of course
they fulfill a certain functionality
and that can be protection um or
um of course food generation and so on
so i try if that works now yeah perfect
so
as designers if we want to design with
fibers textile technology is of course
at hand
so textile is
not a material per se but it is an
operation
for bringing different materialities
together as we see here in this knot so
this knot could actually be produced
from let's say woolen fiber or let's say
metal wires and in each case it would
have a totally different property for
the overall material system but that's
something we are interested in when we
design with fibers
looking at okay i have to see here
sorry
that was too fast
yeah looking at this yarn here for
example
it is a yarn made from cellulose and
when the humidity in the surrounding
increases
this yarn starts moving which it should
do now no you don't see it and because
this yarn is moving
the whole
surface which can be created from that
can be we call that
so physical programming actually
so the swelling is um
is coming into place because um the the
fibers the cellulose fibers they
increase in diameter and therefore by
the twist of the yarn
i can really program this yarn in which
direction to move and i can program even
this weave in which direction to bend
and to fold and so on
by the pattern of the weave by the
direction of the weave by
the strength of the twill so we can
program and design material by designing
the yarn and designing in a higher
hierarchy than
the textile surface
and if we think of that like a larger
screen
suddenly we are in architectural scale
and
we can create these
screens that can really
interact with the environment for
example for climate purposes
and
they rely really on this very small
initial movement only of the cellulose
fiber swelling with humidity
we were then transferring this idea into
really facade scale
of course we had to change materiality
and we were working here with these
smart wires
which is shape memory alloy wires
they
react not to humidity but to temperature
and with increasing temperature they
change their shape
so what we did also the same principle
we interpret these small elements as a
fiber for a larger surface we put them
in
a textile structure and by this we can
really bridge the scales and have very
small
but very active component
into
let's say an
surface which can cover a whole
high-rise building
this green then would react to the outer
temperature let's say sun shines on it
at that moment the screen is closing and
protects the interior from overheating
without any further electricity or
energy needed so really our target
system
here you can see two of the
facade demonstrators which we are just
testing in real environments in
different climate zones
and
finally i'm showing you
small movies about that this elements
are also called muscle wires probably
you see so this
smooth movement really relates to the
movement of muscles
and so the other
one here it's another system
it's not caused on buckling and bending
but this one really on sliding of two
different planes one against each other
and creating this dense or not so dense
sunscreen so to sum it up
my quick introduction into the world of
designing materials from the view of
architecture
what we imagine or what we dream of as
architects is really that we don't think
of of our architects architectures and
buildings as barriers where we want to
protect us with a maximum amount of
material against the environment
but rather to
really make use of the environment make
use of nature to interact with it like a
skin you could say
and generate energy and get in exchange
with
water and
ventilation through wind and all these
things so it's really a re-thinking not
only of the materiality but this has an
impact in the way we could think about
building and about the deployment of
amount of materials for example which
should be used and for buildings
so that was a quick insight from
myself
thank you christiana that's really cool
thank you very much give your hand so
it's really so the shape
changes with the environment this is
really what you're trying to do so you
have reactive
reactive facades reactive materials
without extra energy being put into it
exactly yeah that's the idea of it so
it's ambient energy ambient moisture
do they ever run out of like oomph can
they keep going up and down up and down
they get tired
um well i mean there's always uh
possibilities of course to kind of
overrun the system for the user this is
really important that for example with a
small electrical impulse you could also
change the system but that would be only
very very small amount of energy so
you're not getting
uh
yeah caught or by by the system so yeah
great well i think mark i think your
presentation is ready i think so i think
you're the perfect next next one to
carry on here
great all right well thanks chris and
thank you all for for being here and i'm
i'm really excited to uh yeah add to
what what cristiano said
and add to this idea of rethinking
materiality and i'm i'm here
representing a group of uh faculty from
etihad zurich
and we're starting to think about how we
can use living systems and bring them
into non-living classic engineered
materials
and engage with these living systems to
add new functionality uh to to the
materials that we that we work with
and this group of researchers includes
architects and civil engineers
bioengineers like myself and material
scientists among many others
and we're really yeah we're really
excited about the prospects of this kind
of forward-looking
looking vision
and you know if you took a walk around
the museum today which hopefully you did
it's really a beautiful place and we can
see why living systems are so wonderful
right they have the ability to
sense and respond they adapt and they
evolve
they thrive on relatively few resources
and they decay naturally and these are
all things that we would like to build
into our built environment around us so
that we might have a more sustainable
and more functional uh world that we
engage with
so my lab actually works more on as
chris said on sort of soft squishy
materials and and classically we've been
working on the problem of how can we use
these materials to engineer tissues from
the human body so thinking about how we
can leverage advanced materials design
and advanced processes like 3d printing
and out of manufacturing
to reassemble hierarchical structures
that might restore function in a piece
of of living tissue so here i show a
couple of examples a cardiac valve and a
trachea that we're working on and in
doing this research which again is the
goal is now just to restore function to
a damaged body part we've learned a lot
about how we can engage living systems
with non-living or you know inanimate
materials
and this is a work that is not just
going on in my lab this is work going on
across the world and we as a community
have really learned a lot about how we
can
interface the living and the non-living
and so we at dth and many other centers
around the world are starting to think
about can we take these same concepts
where we take living materials whether
it be mammalian cells so cells from a
human body or other
mammals but or microbes or other living
systems and engage them with inanimate
structures to
rethink our built environment
so if we think about the world around us
when we're walking around the city uh
again like we probably did again in
berlin today we see a lot of beautiful
buildings but they're often sterile and
inanimate
and so one idea for the future might be
that we could think about how we could
bring
life into these uh everyday engineered
materials so one could be can we make
self-healing concrete so can we bring
bacteria in that might sense and heal
micro micro fractures in the material
before we even notice them
or could we bring in bacteria that can
pull down co2 from the environment use
it as part of the building structure and
turn our buildings into co2 sinks
instead of co2 sources
could we also think about how we could
maybe engineer living surfaces that
sense and respond to movement and this
kind of touches on what christiana just
said and could we also think about how
this might work in our own textiles or
our own
structures that we wear on ourselves
again for thinking about how we might
treat the body and and help heal the
body but also now with engineered living
systems
and so why do we focus again on on
building bringing life in and part of
this is that living systems offer
techniques that we as humans can't
really engineer very efficiently and i
think the room that we're sitting in is
a great example so there's all these
beautiful bird specimens around us and
actually birds are really great
engineers of color again as we can see
on display here
and in one example i show here which is
the the blue winged leaf bird they
actually use structural engineering at
the nanoscale to build a protein called
keratin into these gyroid structures
that you that you see in this uh image
here and these structures on the
nanoscale interact with light and they
then give the color that we that we see
and this is very hard for us as
engineers to do so there's a colleague
of mine at eth eric dufresne and many of
his co-workers around the world that are
trying to
adapt this process and really build this
process that we might be able to make
pigment-free beautifully colored
structures and engineered materials and
they're going quite well and they have
really great progress on this but yet
living systems can do these kind of
functions better than we still can as
engineers
and so this motivates us then to think
about where can we maybe embrace or
leverage the benefits of living systems
and try and bring them into some of
other aspects of structures beyond just
maybe making a very nice aesthetically
colored structure we always also bring
in other functions so i'll just give two
very brief examples of things that we're
starting to to think about and so the
first is
in collaboration with with some of my
students so dalla and then also yifan as
well as a colleague at eth benjamin
dillenberger who's in the architecture
department and one of his very creative
students andrea and we're thinking about
how we can use photosynthetic algae
and then build them into printable
materials that i showed you at the
beginning of the the talk
and think about then how we can actually
fabricate
living systems that would be able to
photosynthesize so make their own food
and then build structures with this and
and this specific algae that we're
working with has the ability actually to
use light and resources around to pull
down co2 and mineralize it so it can
then make a you know a ceramic like
material and so the idea would be can we
print these into a structure that we
might envision so here i show a cup for
example
let it incubate or let it take on light
and evolve and then could it actually
then turn into a calcified material and
so some early work that we've shown
seems to indicate that this kind of
process is possible and feasible and so
you can see in this last image that you
actually get a mini mineralized
deposited cop so again this is on a very
small scale it's very early phases but
this paints a picture of what might be
possible in the future of of how we can
pull life into our into our systems
we're also then working on scaling this
up so again these living systems if
built into larger structures like
cristiano showed maybe at the at the
architectural scale could potentially be
used for pulling down carbon and
building this into the structures that
we work with
and just very finally we're also working
again with benjamin's group so they have
really great techniques of of 3d
printing building materials and could we
use these bugs to reinforce these and
stabilize these structures and make them
again adapt and evolve and work with us
so we're really excited about this
possibility of building life into our
built environment around us
and hopefully this gives you at least a
teaser of some of the things that we're
we're thinking about at eth
very cool
that's pretty
wow
so
just algae photosynthesizing
and
building structures that's pretty wild
yeah i think uh again it's it's early
stage but i think it's a good thing to
think about and a good thing and
hopefully the tools that massimo can can
offer us will allow us to do that even
more efficiently
so we've got now the third
person yes we've gone down we're kind of
in different scales here yes
and you're at working at a
nano scale yeah we're working at the
nanoscale and further
yeah yeah atom scale
to a certain extent but i think the core
point is a slightly different one and
it's good to be in the nature
uh um
museum here in in berlin because uh the
truth is that for the first time
in history we can really co-design with
nature and you must say we've been
partnering with nature for centuries or
even millennia but now we can really
co-design and this is a major major
shift in the way we can approach matter
and basically on the one side what is
happening is that we are dramatically
expanding the option space of what is
possible co-designing with nature and
there are a couple of trends that are
happening that are making this possible
on the one side is that um as you're
almost seeing here you have design
coming together with science
with the bridge built between the two
from engineering and before those were
disciplines that were separate are now
coming together allowing to really think
in different paradigms compared to what
was the silos that you had before and on
the other side there is another thing
which is happening which is really
dramatically changing the way we operate
which is that
we have um basically we can manipulate
matter as mark is doing right now but
it's not only that we can manipulate
matter is at a level at the atomic level
but we also have cognition and
computation that is completely rising in
terms of what is possible and
the problem is those two things used to
be apart but what is happening right now
those two things are coming closer and
the way they're coming closer is that
there is a sensing capability and
actuation capability that is bringing
the two together and we can really this
is what allow us to really manipulate
matter and basically co-design with
nature this is happening because of this
combination of things and this is a
major paradigm shift and what is
happening on top of this is because we
are learning quickly and we can design
build tests and learn at every iteration
we get faster so what is happening is
that by we can co-design with nature and
by co-designing with nature we're
exploding the optional space and while
we are collapsing the times by which we
can get there but that's not all the
point if you really
look at what is happening right now
i think that we are in a very particular
historical moment in in our civilization
because the moment in which we are right
now is comparable to the one that we had
10 000 years ago when we moved from
being hunters gatherers to become
farmers it's just what is happening
right now you're seeing what mark is
doing is that we're going from being
hunters gatherers of resources to become
farmer at the atomic level what you've
been doing you start from the cell you
start from organic you start at the
atomic level and what is happening and
is that there is a major major shift
because we go from an exploitative to a
generative and when you go from
exploited to generative you go from a
mindset of scarcity to a mindset of
abundance but and this is not only the
point is that when you do that what
happens as well is that um you have a
degree of precision of what you can do
that it was unthinkable before and you
can start thinking on top of what is
natural and you can start thinking in a
completely different way coming up with
solutions that were unthinkable before
and you can really rethink you the way
you do things uh if you look at the way
we produce nitrogen and today it's
really totally exploitative a lot of
energy is responsible for three four
percent of all the greenhouse gas
emissions and you could say we can try
to optimize this but what is happening
now what if we can design organisms that
fixate nitrogen on the plants instead of
producing nitrogen and this is a
completely different paradigm and you
can apply this you can instead of
extracting leather you can grow leather
using mushrooms you can
sell feeling concrete you can really
produce new material and there are even
companies
there's one company i'm working with
that is now using laser to influence and
shape the geometrical structure at the
atomic level and thus changing the
properties of the material by which
they're working with so they're really
using laser as we're using crispr in
modifying genetic material they're using
it to work on the inorganic side we are
more advanced on the organic side with
the work that mark and other
microbiologists are doing but i think
that the next wave is going to be in the
inorganic side and then we're going to
have a confluence of the two things and
we're entering a new phase for for
humanity in which we can really start
from the atomic level with the degree of
precision that we'd never had before and
really build things it's going to take
it's not going to be an easy journey
because nature is complex so we will
need to learn how to deal with it but i
think that the opportunities that we
have are
incredible
i think that the limitation will be
really in terms of rethinking the
mindset by which we approach things and
really think new solution because the
option space becomes really way way way
bigger orders of magnitude and we will
be able to achieve from a an incremental
increase to a fundamental increase
orders of magnitude i think that's
really quite interesting
sorry where you say rethinking the
mindset so now we have this thing it's
convergence of tools just versions of
opportunity and how we rethink our
mindset of what's actually doable
right and that this is in uh
if we have facades which can actually
truly
react to the environment or combining
the organic inorganic and you talk about
your tools being able to do it
i think it's the mindset part is really
really important because
i said
we need to learn to go back to the
problems and not start from the
solutions one of the biggest problem is
that we tend to start from the solution
and optimize the solution but what we
need to do in this environment if we
really want to rethink materiality we
need to take a step back go back to the
problems and then apply what we can do
now to the problems and come up with new
solutions it's about coming up with new
solutions it's about paradigmatic shift
is not incremental shift that we have
had but we need
the we need to be ready to do that and
and really take a step back and go back
to the problems that's cool
comments
no i i think i i agree with a lot of
what the
massimo said here at the end and i i
think i would like to just emphasize
again that that the tools are really
available now and i agree with this
point about mindset and this is hard to
get people to change and kind of
liberate their mind a little bit and see
that there's there's new opportunities
and
many of them may not work out but we
still need to push and explore them and
and see and this can this can create
many new opportunities for the for the
future this is part of berlin science
week
which is the focus on science and you
all three of you have shown some really
amazing
um steps which we're seeing
and we're trying to also hope to enthuse
next generations for science so
where do you see
all of your work heading so if we look
let's say five years from now
or ten
where do you see where do you see it
going
which is in your mind
okay
we've done it now what
like i've solved
so what now
well if if i can jump in here i have to
coming from the building industry as an
architect
i guess this is one of the probably
slowest changeable industries worldwide
also they are of course one of the
largest consumer of energy worldwide and
producers of waste worldwide so
i would really hope
that our
approaches and um i mean we are working
very textile base but also the
approaches of of both of you um are
totally relevant in this field and i see
a lot of bridges
that that we will manage somehow to um
to change something there and go first
steps um also in industry that they
understand
um that
yeah also as i pointed out like not
working against the environment but that
we really have to understand
buildings and also the surfaces of
buildings the surfaces of our cities
yeah which are just very there's a huge
large surface area not only the roofs
where we have now some photovoltaic
implemented but also the facades
everything so that is a huge potential
and rather not see a facade as a
possible
intersection of of loss and and failure
and so on but really to see it as a
potential of gaining energy and and um
yeah also gaining
um climate um
things for for the building itself and
so on so
um i would really hope
um that the implementation of all this
fantastic science that is just now
really evolving
into society and also into industry
would make a large step forward that
would be one of my largest concerns that
we for example with this project i
showed try to do because we have a
consortium where industry is
from the beginning on involved yeah and
um
yeah i hope that's great to implement
more yeah
do do do we have to implement implement
it it's just a little bit
the more we get the better what about
you guys yeah i mean i might add to this
that i think that there's different you
know
readiness levels of of the different
technologies that we're talking about
and i think that some are really ready
and i think should go and then you know
some of these facade engineering surface
and you know roof engineering we should
we should just do now and implement some
of the stuff that we're working on now i
think it's not ready in five years
probably not even 10 years and i think
in that time scale what i would hope
that we keep pushing is this maybe
challenging the mindset to
think about how we can leverage new
ideas new tools that are available to
come more to a
sustainable approach to doing things i
think there's opportunities in
aesthetics in sustainability um in in
just
rethinking the functionality of the
materials we work with by bringing some
aspects of living systems into them and
even if there are 20 years timeline to
actually become scalable and relevant
it's still good to get people
talking about this and thinking about it
so that our life you know i just had a
child recently and i want his life to be
maybe a little bit less tech heavy and
sterile than the world that i see some
kids growing up in i think i think we
have the tools to do it and i think this
is what i'm excited about
may i stretch the time a little bit go
for it i think i want you to do anything
let's say in 20 years we have to because
we don't have any alternative we're
willing to redo the economic and
industrial tissue that we have and what
does it mean it means that we really
need to shift to this generative
paradigm and concretely it means get rid
completely of all the petrochemical
stuff we need to stop putting energy to
dig stuff out of the ground put energy
to break those molecules down and put
energy to reassemble them to do
additional stuff it's complete nonsense
we should really start doing this and
that's why i go to the 20 years because
i think the next five years are going to
be really important in terms of
transition we're going to have shift in
terms of food food industries going
through a dramatic
transformation and those are ready maybe
not the cultivated meat but everything
in terms of alternative protein we can
produce but really getting the change in
the way we produce stuff is going to be
really important and it's going to be
something which is way more distributed
and less concentrated in which we really
grow stuff and not extract stuff of what
we have and we we're gonna have
different kind of polymers we're gonna
have different kind of materials and and
there is gonna be the first wave is
gonna be really focused on added value
and then over time we're gonna produce
and create the infrastructure to go at
scale and really substitute what is
happening today but
i hope and i think that's the right way
to do it it's not substituting but
create something which is better
because
given the level of precision that we
have we don't need to just come with
alternative protein we can come with
protein which is better than the one
that we have today we can come with
polymers that are better than one today
we can come with polymers that can one
day substitute concrete i know that we
had this discussion and you said
concrete is not bad i think that we can
we can
i hope that we come in 20 years to a
world where concrete is
a thing of the past
i know
i have a sort of long relationship with
concrete so it's a it's a hard one it's
a hard relationship yeah um
so
i won't i i'd say replace things where
you need
the heat the intensity of the heat yes
to to burn
to create the cement i think this is
what we were talking about you think
about growing or crystallizing
we're allowing natural processes yes
that do not require that intense amount
of energy like then i'm on i'm side with
you so
we can also take questions
very now if anyone has any questions
here in the room or on slido i just
remind those who are online you're
welcome to put something into lito and
i'll integrate those into conversation
does anybody have a question here in the
room right now if so i need you to put a
hand up
and there's one up here and then there's
one in the way back as well great
okay
we'll take both the questions and
thanks very much for sharing your
thoughts and ideas on this exciting
topic
um when we discuss
living materials i'm i'm wondering to
which degree are these living materials
and their behavior
unpredictable
oh
interesting question and we're going to
take the woman in the way back elizabeth
you could grab it
all the way to the back
we're going to take both of those to
what degrees
oh
i'm glad you didn't ask what's life
that would have been
yeah
oh you want to go ahead okay good i'm
happy to jump in on that all right and
so okay so this is something we think
about a lot i think it's a fantastic
question and and you know
living systems as we said they evolve
and they adapt and that leads to
inherent unpredictability and every time
we try and cage them in they find a way
out and and this is i mean for me makes
super fun research questions of how can
we
work with that i don't think about and
massimo said this to me before just
before we came on that sometimes we try
and cage in biology too much and i agree
with this so we sort of need to engage
and embrace it and see if we can
work with it instead of thinking that
we're
you know above biology we're just a part
of it all right and we're probably not
going to impose strict boundaries on it
but this makes for if you think about
infrastructure you want a time scale of
decades and if you have something that
is changing on you on the time scale of
days or months or years it's really hard
to think about how that's going to work
and this is one of the clear challenges
that we that we need to
address and engage with so i think it's
a fantastic question and so we haven't
solved it but
i think the community will keep working
on it
yeah i would also like to jump in on
that because
from designers point of view i have to
say we also have to change the way we
design
i think the design has to become
different it has to become more robust
i think that this idea of designing for
like a very very specific purpose and it
has to fit right that and it is
engineered to exactly this purpose we
have to step back from that and to
really think about yeah designs which
are more open
so that can also like in terms of
the way something can take on there
would be a
wider range or about the shape something
so a wall could just differ between this
and that thickness but it would always
be a wall which is good enough to bear
that load that is going to be
implemented like a tree for example also
has different branches and they all play
together but it's not that this tree has
to have this diameter this branch this
and that diameter so in that sense i
also think we have to rethink design and
that's something very um very basic
um
trying to rethink robustness what is
that yeah and i want it to be
i think the question is
very good and i think that there is an
underlying question and statement that
is very dear to my heart because i think
in this process we need basically to get
rid of 300 years of newtonism in which
we really think in terms of cause and
effect which is really beautiful because
you can think that you can do a and you
get b we need to completely forget this
because we're entering a space that is
way more complex we need to realize the
fact that complexity and and noise is a
feature of nature is not a bug and we
need to stop trying to say okay let's
eliminate the noise we need to really
embrace it and embrace the complexity
that comes with it and really look at
for emergence and not cause an effect
interesting
thank you
back in the corner for the interesting
lecture which was incredibly interesting
and i actually have a question to
cristiano and massimo for christianity i
know that there is some solar panels
that can be actually coated like
the windows can be coated with the solar
panels and this energy can be
accumulated
and used for future use do you think
it's now appliable for building the
buildings or
and another question is to massimo if
you said that it's we should get rid of
the petroleum and stop taking it out
but do you know anything any new
compounds that can be used instead
except lithium batteries
so can you repeat the last sentence do
you know any other compounds that can be
used
instead of petroleum except lithium
batteries
yeah
okay we've got uh two two questions you
got two for one you know they would
usually get one question per person
but we're generous today
okay so christian yeah i have to ask
quickly back so
i mean you were talking about these um
coatings for for windows and then the
question was photovoltaic so there's the
thin film photovoltaics which you can
now thin film photovoltaic onto onto
facades yeah yeah i mean that that's a
that's a technology which is um of
course
super interesting
um also in terms of flexible building
skins because you can put them also on
on flexible substrates and there has
been first
projects and and thought about
also for example coating coating yarn
with it
so um
but of course you could have then
screens or curtains which you can slide
away when there is sun and um or slight
slides together when there is sun and
slide away when there is no sun and so
on of course this is a super interesting
technology also for for textile thinking
okay then massimo petroleum replacement
products plenty of
um
you can
so
it depends petroleum is used in many
many things we even eat products that
come out of petroleum but petroleum is
basically a polymer is a long chain of
atoms
carbon
atoms and basically they store the
energy ultimately they came from the sun
and then got buried and then very
intense they have very high intensity in
terms of uh energy uh condensed there
and then they're different way you can
go this way depending on where you are
in the chain of of petroleum but
starting with hydrogen hydrogen
is becoming a replacement possible for
these things and when you come to the
polymer or monomer side of things you
can really design bacteria to produce
all of this stuff and there are people
that are doing it
you can use algae you can
use a lot of
organisms to be able to do it so it's
it's not a matter right now it's more a
matter of scale and price um but i know
that many many companies are really
trying to read there is a cosmetic
company we're working with they have
still 25 of the product they're using
petrochemical but they're making a huge
effort to get rid of all of it um so we
don't actually we don't we don't need
petroleum we can do it uh differently
that's actually very inspiring to hear
that
so are there other questions any other
questions here in the room
because i'm going to give you a chance
to i'm going to ask him then i'm going
to ask him one question and come back to
you so you said something about
photosynthesis
so you have algae which you are now
manipulating the photosynthetic
properties of them they already have it
we're not they already have it
introducing so you've so you've figured
out photosynthesis i don't know
okay
there are so many but there are there
are people who are doing this yeah and
and basically one of the things that is
happening right now is that we're
shifting away the word today is very
much based on thermal catalysis is
basically the petroleum and the energy
that you get out of it but we can
produce and when i say we're going to
move into a generative place is that
we're starting instead of going from
bigger molecules break them apart and
extract energy what we're doing we're
taking the sun and taking the photons
translating them into electrons and
getting from the smaller to the bigger
that's what it means to become um
narrative okay and and and we're doing
this and there are people that are
really looking and basically
create
doing photo
light based catalysis so to say so that
there are people doing that working that
they're not there yet though
in biological systems you can take
something that naturally has
the know-how the internal
systems to photosynthesize and produce
materials and with biofoundries and
tools like this we can now augment or
work with that system to try and improve
the process so this is what i think will
be needed to take
natural systems that we really work with
and and leverage is how can we kind of
guide them given the caveat that it's
going to want to change on us as was
pointing to everyone could you imagine
that coming up to us you you gave one
example where you work with benjamin on
a building scale but you imagine like
some of the work that christian is
showing
how could that come into the facades
yeah i mean i think we we also think
about sort of sprayable materials or
other things that you could put onto the
surface where the surface might be
living now and and maybe it's just
sensing and communicating to some
activated textile or maybe it's
depositing material
yeah
these things i think are yeah are
imaginable
we had a project um where we we
basically created bricks
that were leveraging uh urine to produce
electricity using bacteria so you have
in your house and you produce
electricity using your so you pee on the
brick yeah
it goes through the brick okay
seriously yes
how much
electricity a lot sorry how much
electricity not not that much okay
it was just a proof of concept all right
well but still that's pretty
i mean this is what you're saying
rethinking what's normal what's real
this is really interesting how you can
imagine that so i'm asking the same
question when you when you hear some of
the work that they were just talking
about could you imagine how some of this
could come into your work
excuse me could you imagine how some of
what mark was talking about could come
into your work oh yes of course yeah i
already see it there i mean we we have
to start cooperating
immediately
and
sure i mean the the the difference is
that what we do basically i mean we work
together also with
biomaterial scientists with biologists
and so on but not in the sense that we
really use the biological material but
what we have is this kind of
bioinspiration what we call so
what's interesting and then in terms of
textiles is that the the the
hierarchical building up of structures
of material systems that we find in
nature
so what i showed can can one-to-one be
transferred as an idea into the idea of
fiber becoming a yarn a yarn becoming a
textile weave a texture we've becoming a
surface and so on and and by this
um
i think
there is a really close connection to um
to biology and
and textile thinking and of course
when we talk about biomaterials
it's super interesting because text size
can also
provide a large surface
by the fiber structure so that would be
an ideal ground for fertilizing with um
whatever kind of biological systems or
urine for example
so we have a question right here down
the front
and then we have another other questions
go right here left front left or front
right
nope yep
it's uh rather a comment to the question
asked before
and so how much
we can replace of our fossil based
materials already with a bio alternative
and it's because i'm working in that
field it's over ninety percent much more
it's rather as massimo said the question
of
um scaling but also um
communication because at the moment our
um we talk a lot um about recycling and
this is not really getting to the root
of the problem um especially in a
context of a circular economy we um yeah
we have we have to think rather of
biological
materials that the earth can process and
at the same time when we when we look
that and when we produce products eight
and eighty percent
of all the emissions and also waste is
is created um
before or with the production so what
comes out is actually only the tip of
the iceberg and so i think um yeah this
whole event is very important to spread
the knowledge and more of that
thank you so i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna actually interpret your statement
into a question
which is
um if we're going to achieve this goal
of getting towards a truly and
bio-inspired
uh regenerative generative
society and materials based
you know
what are like the top the next the next
three steps you said is 20 years away
you said 20 you're doing this work night
now
how scalable how quick
what needs to happen in order for us to
get there it's not i think it's not just
mindset within a consumer standpoint
there's got to be other there's a few
other things so we can get these
rethinking the way we think about the
materials
what so
20 years is
it's the time we have to make it happen
so that's when it close i think the next
five years are going to be crucial
um in terms of scalability this is one
of the biggest challenges while dealing
with nature because as mark was saying
it's
we cannot tell nature what to do
things evolve and we need to learn how
to do uh with it and also we need to
rethink
also the dealing with with biology
because so far it has been really
characterized and driven by biofarmer
where you really have tiny quantities
huge value but it's not set up to deal
to to support the kind of production
that we need for this so scalability is
one of the issues but on the other side
i think that
on the positive side is
because we have a generative piece there
is a limit in terms of efficiency that
you can gain getting bigger actually
there is a point after which you have
these economies of scale and therefore
then it's going to become a
way more distributed environment where
you have smaller distributed production
facilities facilities that are we're
going to go to a place to go build on on
the comment before where we're going to
move from value chains into value nets
where you have what is the waste stream
from one piece become the the feedstock
for the next process and it's it's more
you're starting already seeing these and
there are companies that are at the
steel plants that are taking the exhaust
gases use bacteria to produce um
different things even uh fuel with it
but it's just gonna are we gonna just
get is this gonna be an another northern
western
advance and just to find a way for us to
carry on or is this truly gonna be able
to be something which goes goes global
it has it has two but you can see
already singapore is quite advanced and
actually they have a bit of an advantage
for certain things because they don't
have the regulatory uh
hurdles that we have and they're really
quick to bring things to market china is
investing dramatically we just don't
know but
or they're not going in in in the public
but they're doing incredible stuff
on on the biology side um and all of the
all of a sudden we're going to wake up
and realize that they're
ahead of us because they're really
putting a lot of money and then
but i think the point that you're making
uh there is a very important comment to
be done here is that this evolution
cannot be top down and as it is evolving
and we don't know yet what is going to
come out completely we need to engage in
a dialogue with society to really think
through what are the second and third
order consequences and being open that
we don't know but we want to have a
dialogue to make sure that it goes in
the right direction because so often
with science we expect you to know yeah
that's your job to know
right so we don't like that
i don't know answer right so another
question
gizbert had one does anyone else have a
question
i know you have quite i could just see
these thought bubbles
going off all over there
then all right gizbert yeah i'm not
trying to hijack
i know you i know you're not that's what
i'm saying come on everyone truly
curious here because um
nasty question um 30 35 years ago we had
very similar discussions
about bionics taking over uh
manufacturing evolution theory uh
inspiring scientific discovery
what makes you so confident that this
time this idea of bio-inspired materials
is here to stay
good question
so again i can go for it
go for it so i wasn't there for the
conversation 35 years ago
i was as old as my son is now i guess so
a few months old then but
um i but i see the point and i first of
all i would say i'm not so confident
that it's here to stay and that we're
gonna solve everything i think that's
would be too too much hubris to say that
but i think that we have many more tools
in the synthetic biology side or how to
think about how we can engage with
biology not just as passive observers
but people who can work with it now
and that those tools were starting maybe
a few decades ago but now they're much
more advanced and you know we can
for not too much money talk to massimo
buy a whole gene circuit and encode you
know new new genetic circuits in into
bugs and and have them work with us and
add new functionalities to a system
again that doesn't mean that that now
it's solved and that's going to work but
i think we have new tools on that side
we have new materials and processing
tools and i think that we have more
demand from society for something that
is a bit more
sustainable that is more uh yeah
yeah i guess the sustainable is what i
would say is this
yeah i would like to add there because i
i think this formal discussion was very
much a top-down discussion also from
this um
point of view from from high tech high
technology
only very skilled people or institutions
could solve things and so on
and
being at an art school and design school
here in berlin i have to say that i
really feel it very strongly from from
what you just said so from societal
impact and that people young designers
young young young people they go out and
they do these startups and and they
really try and even with very simple
means sometimes they they they try and
they they succeed to change something
and
so i think it's more like at this time
this grassroot
and and very implemented in society
movement but on the other side
as max said i'm also not
convinced or i can't guarantee also but
i think it's the only thing that we can
do is to try
and we don't have another
way to go at the moment
massimo
also because
we don't have an alternative yeah we
really don't have an alternative and we
really sorry if i keep going there but
we really need to change the paradigm
and really rethink because an
exploitative model
starts with a finite amount of stuff and
it's a scarcity model it's not
sustainable as we're seeing so we need
to change this and i'm bullish because
even five years ago mark will confirm we
were not able to do the stuff that we're
doing um and and
we are you know we were able to do
i give you a a data point um normally
when you play with dna you usually you
are between five and ten thousand base
pairs to give you terms of reference the
human body has three billion uh base
pairs so we are able to synthesize and
put together between five and ten
fifteen thousand is the place and to
give an idea the team where we are now
so we are now we can deliver 42 000 base
pair so this is just really happening
now and we're starting we're moving and
we're going to go to over 100 thousand
there is a limit to what you can do
there but the important thing is that
the first time we did it it took us six
months the second time we did it it took
us three months the last time we did it
took us 21 days and you're seeing this
is this is what i was saying it's the
expanding of the option space but the
collapsing of the time and that's why i
think that we're going to really see
more and more of this happening and it's
already happening today i met yesterday
with the startup here in berlin and they
produce whey and casein is basically
they're doing cheese out of bacteria
it's happening now it's not the future
and they just raise money to do it and
it's going to be soon in the supermarket
so i think that's actually a really
wonderful question to
come to our closing ramp
i'm going to add something to that
because i think
as you've indicated i think from your
tools without the computational capacity
which we now have
this would not be possible absolutely
not right for me and you say from your
high-tech side you couldn't even imagine
and again this is as i said at the very
beginning a material scientist's dream
20 years ago that when i could ever even
begin to think about this so i think
that's number one number two is you've
indicated there's an urgency
and i think that is felt not only
by us but by generations all over the
world
so i think there's this this is where i
think we have a better chance this time
around with this urgency and the third
five the third is this the global
awareness
i think this is also becoming something
which is quite intriguing that your work
can now go global very quickly we become
more aware of global trends but there's
also global expectation
you know that you think globally you act
locally but now
the next one is frugal and frugal
innovation
this comes to responding to what you
said about this has been very top down
but there's also
a massive movement with frugal
innovation so when we begin when we
begin to be able to have your
distributed
distilleries or bio foundries bio
foundry hello here we go i'm getting
ready i'm getting ready for the apparel
looking at the wine bottles over there
going okay and a beer no if you think
about this able this capability of
getting
out and distributed yes
i think this is also this frugal
innovation is really needed and
recognized
and i think and that end with that is
there is no choice
there is no
planet b
or planet c or d or e
so this is this is the one beautiful one
that we have but we only have 20 years
that's why we've got 20 years i'd say we
have 10. yeah well you're right so you
know this is what we're this is where
we're about yep so i want to thank you
three very very much for a delightful
conversation i love talking with smart
people
and all of you completely satisfied my
thirst for learning and i want to learn
more about your work um but thank you
for sharing your wisdom and your passion
with us and let us give them a round of
applause thank you say thank you
and i wish to thank all of you
very very much for choosing to come here
to join us either online or here in the
room um for this
rethinking materiality conversation we
do have another conversation which the
eth zurich will be hosting tomorrow at
11 o'clock entitled the robots are
coming
and you can also join that virtually
unfortunately there are no more
seats and you can find information for
that on our website
or on the website of the berlin science
week
and
we would like to invite all of you who
are here and i wish i could invite all
of you online as well but i can't
to have a a drink of
something alcoholic or none and a bit of
a nibble
and to continue conversation with our
guests
so with that thank you very very much
and
see you soon
[Applause]